we're probably ready to record so yeah
um
so thank you for being here and uh for
giving this talk
and uh please go ahead
thanks alex uh thanks for
tuning in whoever is on youtube or
whoever is live thank you thanks for
tuning in for this talk and also thanks
for the opportunity to present at this
reunion
i'm going to talk about this work price
of active security and multi-party
computation it's actually a confluence
of
a few works in the last couple of years
you know joined with these wonderful
co-authors
this talk is about secure multi-party
computation as all of you know
mpc allows a group of mutually
distrustful parties to jointly compute a
function
over their private inputs where nothing
but the output is revealed
mpc comes in many flavors you can ask
about adversaries that passively or
actively corrupt parties passive
corruption
means the adversary
corrupts the party follows the protocol
but tries to learn more than it should
act of corruption or what i would say
full security is
when an adversary can corrupt a party
and act arbitrarily byzantine
a second classification is based on the
number of parties corrupted
there are two distinct settings here
based on techniques and so forth
one is honest majority where the
adversary is only allowed to corrupt a
minority
of the parties and the second setting
is where the adversary can corrupt all
but one
i'm going to focus on one result for the
most of the talk and
it's going to be for the setting of
getting active corruption
tolerating active adversaries that can
corrupt
all but one parties
mpc design typically follows these two
steps you first
build a protocol that withstands a
passive adversary and then you amplify
it to
uh full security or withstand byzantine
adversaries
this talk is about what is the overhead
of going from passive to active in the
past decade
we have seen like several tremendous
improvements in passive protocols like
now they're
pretty efficient we are you know looking
at so many protocols for even neural
network computations
but the overhead of moving from passive
to active still
uh seems a bottleneck
i want to say the state of the art
is that when you want to move from
passive to active there is
a blow up of order s where s is the
statistical security parameter
and i'm kind of focusing on the
concretely efficient constructions
uh when i when i say this uh in practice
also when you see the passive to active
override this is like between 20 to 100
x
and it doesn't scale well also in terms
of number of parties
in this talk i'm going to talk about how
to make this overhead
a constant and with also concrete
efficiency
in mind and we're going to show for
certain cases it it can be made
close to two uh as i said again i'm
focusing on concretely efficient
constructions if you want
in you know in theory you can get a
constant communication
uh overhead
so what's the state of the art
first in theory why can you get constant
communication overhead well you take an
arbitrary passive protocol
you can apply the classic gmw paradigm
of attaching zero knowledge proofs
and even better if you use a succinct
zero knowledge argument or a snark
then to get an active protocol you
simply have to
for example commit to your input and
randomness and then
attach a zero knowledge proof to every
message i'm simplifying here but this is
essentially what you
what the gmw paradigm uh tells us and if
these proofs are short
the overhead of getting active security
in terms of communication
uh is is quite it's quite small it's in
fact less than two
if the zero knowledge is small enough
but in practice the passive protocol the
way they amplify
to get active is using this paradigm
which is cut and choose and
most practical constructions use this
form of cut and choose one way or the
other
now i want to talk about where you get
this order
s overhead roughly speaking in all these
works what you do is you consider
a slightly modified version of the
passive protocol and
run it end times now the reason you want
to run it 10 times is because each party
is now going to
check the other party on how it behaved
in some of these copies in other words
we're going to open your inputs and
randomness for some of these
some of these executions and see if you
behaved properly
now say alice is going to check bob on t
copies now uh if you set you know t
appropriately just by a simple churn off
bond you can
you can you can argue that if bob passes
this test
then for most of these uh
executions of this modified passive
protocol
bob must have behaved honestly and
then you apply some clever kind of
combiner to to get
your result now the main point here is
that
if you want a statistical security of 2
to the minus s you need at least
uh you know s copies and this is where
the order s
overhead comes from so what i want to
talk about is how do i
how do i make this overhead a constant
but even defining this problem is a
little hard
because you know in theory you can make
it a constant so what do i mean by
making you know this overhead constant
so
to to do this what we're going to do is
we are
going to define a primitive
based on which we'll be able to analyze
this uh this metric
so i'm going to talk quickly everyone
knows what secret sharing is
in additive secret sharing you can share
a secret between two parties where
neither individual can identify x beyond
one over f
uh probability where f is the field size
over which this is being sacred shared
now for such a secret sharing scheme if
you want to
you know mpc protocols are based on this
if you want to
do a secure addition on shares this is
easy if i have an additive secret
sharing scheme i can locally add
and i can get secret sharing of the uh
of the result of this edition now
multiplication
in other words addition is free you can
do this locally if you choose an
additive secret sharing scheme but if
you want multiplication on the other
hand which is the same thing i have
secret shares
of two secrets a and b and i want to get
secret shares of the product
this on the other hand requires uh
communication
okay so uh i just want to quickly tell
you the the classic gmw protocol for
securely computing any function in the
in the passive setting it works as
follows you know alice and bob
additively secret share their inputs to
each other and then they do a gate by
gate evaluation where
addition gates can be locally evaluated
as i just mentioned
and for multiplication gate you use some
protocol
you know to do a secure multiplication
so you just keep doing it for all the
multiplication gates the addition gates
you do it locally
and then finally you broadcast the
secret shares of the output
this is the classic gmw protocol and in
fact
you know the secure multiplication that
you need
needs to be only passively secured
because i'm only talking about a
passively secured protocol
and if you look at the complexity of
this protocol in terms of secure
multiplication
i need one call to a secure
multiplication
gadget per multiplication gate of the
circuit or
you can think of it per and gate of the
circuit for
boolean computations so the reason i
presented this is to say that the main
question
we are going to ask over here you know
to frame a question of getting
a good overhead we're going to ask what
is the overhead of achieving
active security given only black box
access
to a passive implementation of secure
multiplication
and the reason we're going to say black
box x is because this is more efficient
in practice if you don't use
the code of the the the protocol you're
using for secure multiplication
in other words like taylor made zero
knowledge proofs then uh you know your
your construction is going to be uh more
efficient so
restricting black box access to such a
gadget
we're going to ask what is the overhead
of getting active security
and as we just saw before if i just
wanted passive security i just need one
call per
multiplication gate so the state of the
art
when i you know restrict our question to
this model is
something like this and you know for the
boolean and arithmetic question
arithmetic computation in the two-party
setting it's constant
but for arbitrary parties there is still
this order as overhead
and what we do in this work is
we show that we can make this a constant
and i mentioned that this is for the
dishonest majority
setting uh with active security
our framework is general enough that it
can also capture and you know provide
the same result for
the honest majority setting as well
so the main theorem that we showed this
uh
is from the eurocrypt uh paper this year
is
we show that we can construct an
actively secure multiparty computation
for
arbitrary functions over some finite
field making only constant invocations
of a passive implementation of secure
multiplication protocol
per multiplication gate of the circuit
and this in fact like in practice you
know we implemented this for the two
party setting and i'll show you some
graphs
we can show that you know we get roughly
two for large
uh finite fields so i have a question
sorry
yes is the is there any other
um communication beyond whatever is
implied by calling the
secure mall yes and uh and is that
dominated by the
the one that is in the theorem or or
yes that's right i mean the there are
like smaller like additive terms that
would that would come in the
uh
i mean it will be dominated by the
uh by the by the passive protocol for
secure multiplication that's right
thanks okay so in terms of techniques
uh the main technique that you know we
follow is this
uh paradigm introduced by ishai
prabhakaran and sahai called the ips
paradigm so here you want to i mean when
you want to construct an actively secure
protocol
with dishonest majority you can compose
in in fact in a nice i want to say even
kind of black boxes way
of two two different kinds of protocols
with different guarantees
so you can combine an active mpc with in
the honest majority setting
with a passive mpc with the dishonest
majority setting you can combine these
two
ingredients to get an active mpc with
dishonest majority
now these are mild building blocks in
fact we have very good protocols for
both these settings the passive
you just saw it you can just think of
the classic gmw
protocol and for this there are very
nice protocols to get
uh active mpc in the in the honest
majority setting
and just following i mean i i won't use
it too much we call
you know the honest majority the outer
protocol and the dishonest majority as
the
you know the inner protocol
so what i'm going to do quickly is uh
i'm going to go over
uh this paradigm
and then tell like where uh what
we do in our work so what is active mpc
with an honest majority the way we
we can think of this is you have clients
that you know secret share
their inputs to servers and an adversary
can actively corrupt
all but one of the clients and can
corrupt
at most half of these servers okay
so this is the first ingredient that we
want and such a computation typically
proceeds as follows you know alice and
bob
secret share their input to the servers
the servers do the computation
and then they provide the answer back to
alice and bob okay the the second
ingredient
is passive uh mpc with dishonest
majority
again i'm showing it in the two-party
setting whatever i'm saying uh also
uh makes sense in the multi-party
setting
so this is a passive protocol in the
dishonest
majority setting an adversary can
passively corrupt
at most one client okay so how do we
combine these two ingredients the basic
idea is
i mean in the real world you only have
the clients these are the participants
that you want with dishonest majority
now the first ingredient involves
servers
but this these are really not there now
the way you're going to do this is the
we're going to use the outer protocol
which is the honest majority setting to
actually
compute the function that you care about
okay so this
is what this is is going to do the
computation the inner protocol
is actually going to be used to emulate
these servers that
you know are only that only exist
virtually or
in the parties heads so you can imagine
that
you know each of these servers the
actions executed by each of these
servers are actually going to be done
via a passive inner protocol
okay so as such when they are executing
this protocol neither alice or bob
actually knows any of these servers
unless they cheat in the passive
inner protocol if they don't cheat then
actually they can compute this function
and this would be
secure but the point is this is only
part the inner protocol is only
passively secure which means you know
alice or bob can cheat and by cheating
they can violate the privacy of
uh you know uh the outer protocol
so in order to make this thing work a
key idea in this ips paradigm
is the notion of a watch list where
alice
watches bob on bob's action on a few of
these servers
and bob watches alice on a few of these
servers
and the what happens is that if
bob cheats in too many then it's going
to be cut and if alice cheats in too
many
bob is going to catch alice and in a
nutshell what happens is that by setting
k
appropriately you can make sure that
neither alice nor bob
can cheat in in the virtual emulation of
the servers
in you know at most uh you know
a minority of these servers so now
the security of the outer protocol kicks
in because even
because this is actively secured even if
a minority of these servers
were bad we we get the result of the
computation will be correct
and private this is the ips paradigm in
a in a nutshell and the key idea here
is of course you know combining the
outer protocol with the inner protocol
but using the watch list to enforce the
requirements
of the outer protocol
so talking about the efficiency of the
ips paradigm imagine we have n clients
we have m servers
and k watch lists the efficiency of the
system is roughly m by k
you know if you use a good outer
protocol which has like you know using
like back secret sharing and so forth
you can get the efficiency to be m by k
now
k you should think of the watch list you
should think of it as the corruption
threshold of uh you know roughly the
corruption threshold of the outer
protocol
so you can construct good ones where m
by k
is actually a constant this is this is
easy
now to get 2 to the oh it should be
minus but if you want to get
you know 2 to the minus s soundness
error you need at least
the number of servers needs to be at
least the security parameter
now again you can ask oh now am i going
to have the same
issue as the classic you know the cut
and choose paradigm the answer is no
because
this computation is amortized it's okay
if the number of servers
is a lot but the second constraint here
is the one that's actually a little more
tricky now
if you have i i showed the diagram for
two parties but if you had many many
parties
each party needs an individual watch
list that none of the others know
okay so but if n minus one of the
parties collude then n
minus one of the parties can watch n
minus one times k of the servers
now this is the total number of servers
they can watch this needs to be less
than
the corruption threshold of the outer
protocol which means n minus 1 times k
should be less than m by 2.
and what happens because of this is that
your the ips paradigm in the multi-party
setting like i mean for constant number
of parties it works you get like good
constant overhead and this is what i
mentioned at the beginning
but when you think of arbitrary parties
there is
uh you you will suffer an additional
overhead of number of clients
in the complexity so the ips paradigm is
is great but it doesn't work for beyond
constant number of parties
okay so this is where our work begins
and
our approach is not to have individual
watch lists
but actually to have a global watch list
now this
doesn't make sense like i mean it's not
like everyone will be
uh watching all the time
a set of these servers but at the end of
the day there will only be a single
subset of servers that need to be
watched
and the idea is you don't like in the
ips paradigm
you can check if the other party is
cheating or not during the computation
because you will have
complete view of these servers you can
check during the computation if
something is going wrong
but when we move to global watch list
actually we can't do this
because if everyone knew which server i
am watching they'll make sure they won't
cheat there
so you know that's not going to work so
the set of servers that they're going to
you know check has to be revealed at the
end and also the correctness needs to be
checked at the end
okay so this is our first key insight
into making
this ips paradigm for arbitrary number
of parties so what's the challenge
the the adversary of course you know now
as i said it can violate the privacy of
the inner
inner protocol this it can always do
because it's only
a passively secure now by violating the
inner
protocol you violate the privacy of the
outer protocol now if you're checking
things at the end this is going to be a
problem because during the computation
if all privacy is gone
i've already learned your input i don't
even need to wait till the end of the
computation
and sorry
right so how do we solve this so
our next idea here is that
we're going to choose an inner protocol
that is weakly private
it is not again this is just i'm
oversimplifying the idea
finally we need only a passively secured
inner protocol but
the way we instantiate our inner
protocol it will be
weakly private okay which means that
during the protocol the adversary cannot
violate privacy it can of course violate
correctness
but and then you make a tailor-made
outer protocol
where this privacy carries forward
so in other words these two ingredients
what happens is that
during the protocol even if the
adversary cheats in all executions of
all the servers
it will not violate the privacy of the
honest party's inputs
and then finally you check
the correctness for a subset of the
servers before revealing the output
and this kind of solves the problem
and i should say i'm not going to go
more details into how this works
but you know it is the main technical
contribution is how to make this outer
protocol that
preserves privacy
okay so here is just a quick graph on
uh uh for the two-party setting we
didn't implement it yet for the
the multi-party setting uh you can see
the bottom
lines here is just for the passive
protocol
and then the next line here is our
implementation
of uh the
[Music]
the active protocol and this is
communication and this is time
and this is uh the best uh
previous protocol due to overdrive color
at all
and you know we start with roughly like
4x
overhead and you know as we increase the
circuit size
this tends to you know two
now to be just want to say that
there is also another metric that if you
want to know you can ask how many times
do we call the secure multiplication
this doesn't quite show it because this
is the end-to-end communication of our
protocol
but there's a table in the graph in our
paper if you want to see
the as we go at close to like i think
half a million gates if your circuit is
half a million gates
then the number of times i have to call
the passive implementation of a secure
multiplication is close to a two
for large fields okay
how much time this this log where um
line does it represent a protocol with
what
uh overhead asymptotically
uh which one the the low gear oh sorry
low gear no lock where low gear
so they use like tailor-made
zero-knowledge proof so i re i
i can't quite tell what the the
asymptotic complexity is
all right thanks uh
and you know a similar you know you can
see uh for
the the run time of the passive versus
active how much time do i have ali
you're doing uh good you have 15 minutes
okay great
i think i might finish uh faster but
anyway so let me
uh so so you know the main theorem
uh that we show is there exists an
actively secure multiparty computation
that makes
constant indications of any passive
implementation
of a secure multiplication uh protocol
and you know
the number of invocations is constant
per multiplication gate of the circuit
uh i want to say that you know this
outer and inner the way i described was
you know the inner protocol is a passive
dishonest majority if you replace it
with a passive
honest majority you can also get a final
protocol for the honest majority setting
and i want to say that one of the
results that we improve here is for the
boolean setting we didn't know before
a passive to active with constant
overhead
uh and as i mentioned it's in practice
you can get this
like the uh the overhead to be uh two
for large
uh finite fields we implemented it for
two parties and we've not implemented it
yet for multi-parties but i'm going to
tell you
something more about the the multi-party
setting
uh so a couple of questions from you
know these work
from this work is that
what about concrete efficiency the
boolean sitting so i've been telling
that we get in practice too for large
finite fields but what happens
for the boolean setting or small fields
and we do get a conflict the main
theorem holds but it's not concretely
efficient and the main reason is
we have to rely on algebraic geometric
codes we need secret sharing where
the size of each share is also small
so and these are at least not yet proven
to be
efficient in uh in practice
another question that we're going to ask
is can we get you know less than two
and also concretely efficient so
question
the the ag codes do you use them for
their multiplication property yes
okay
so we're going to answer this like a
couple of these questions in them
specific settings and we're going to say
that
you know we have to relax this black box
condition that we have
and given to some of these snarks
like so and also go closer to the gmw
paradigm itself so we're going to show
that you know
in some of these settings we can
actually get something that's concretely
efficient by following the gmw paradigm
itself
and that's what i'm going to talk about
next so
this is uh you know a recent work from
ccs this year
it's about getting boolean two-party uh
computation
now we know the classic protocol for uh
the passive setting
in the uh for boolean circuits it's
yao's protocol
and here's just a you know a small
picture of how this works
you have a gobbler you have an evaluator
the garbler gobbles the secret
the the circuit and also the
the inputs in in a special form and then
it transmits
you know the gobble circuit and the
gobbled inputs to the evaluator
its own inputs it can send it directly
but evaluators inputs have to be
received via an oblivious transfer
so this is kind of the best protocol and
in fact you know this is
uh again we've seen a lot of improvement
in the
in the last decade of implementing this
we can do like billion gates
uh uh secure computation uh
with yao's protocol
so how do we get active security here
essentially we're going to follow the
gmw paradigm we're going to say let's
attach a zero knowledge proof
okay now we're going to have a zero
knowledge proof that goes from the
gargler to the
evaluator now gmw paradigm requires you
know zero knowledge proofs both ways
like to show both actions are
uh you know both of them act uh
correctly
but the nice thing of uh the years
protocol is if the oblivious transfer
is in fact malicious or actively secure
then the evaluator can cheat it is
already secure against an act of
corruption of an evaluator so the only
thing you want to protect is an act of
corruption
of the guard block so you know the
garbler proves that
it constructed the gobble circuit
correctly it garbled its own input
correctly and it provided
the evaluators input in the oblivious
transfer correctly
so this zero knowledge proof essentially
needs to prove these three statements
now in our implementation actually we
were careful about applying this gmw
paradigm and by that i mean
uh this np statement that we pick to
prove over here
is in fact will be black box in the
oblivious transfer
input outputs but not black box only in
the
pseudo-random generator so we are
relaxing our
you know requirement of being black box
but we're being selective about it we
are only saying that look
the prg that's used to build the global
circuit will be non-black box
in it in the zero knowledge proof but be
black box in the oblivious transfer
so how do we do this so we extend
this oblivious transfer functionality to
a slightly more general functionality
that we call
certified oblivious transfer and i'm
going to tell you what this is
so in a certified oblivious transfer you
and here is a parallel version of
certified oblivious transfer you want to
do many
uh oblivious transfers in parallel if
you recall in the yaw's protocol you
could do
all of the evaluators input in in
parallel
so you um
the certified wbs transfer is
parameterized by an np relation
r that
that performs the following
functionality it
delivers the input of the oblivious
transfers
to the receiver only if this relation
holds with respect to some public
statement x that
both the sender and receiver know and
some private witness that the sender
holds
and the inputs of the sender
okay so the certified oblivious transfer
says that look i can apply an np
relation
black box on the inputs outputs of the
oblivious transfer
and some other public statement and this
is exactly what we need
in the house protocol so
what is the point of abstracting this
functionality is that
we show how to implement this certified
oblivious transfer
with black box access to oblivious
transfer and a commit and pro
zero knowledge and we have black box in
the commitment as well but
we can use these two in a black box way
to implement the
certified oblivious transfer i won't
give this protocol but
this is kind of the main technical
novelty and we we implemented
uh we implemented this the
the high level takeaway from doing this
uh this work was that we could you know
this is feasible like with the you know
current improvements in in zero
knowledge
this is possible and we get our
communication
is smaller than twice the size of the
passive protocol
and we don't even need to go for very
large circuits you know even for
moderately big circuits we can show that
the zero knowledge proof we have to
attach is smaller than the entire
protocol itself which means the overhead
is less than two
our implementation however we couldn't
go more than uh
i think we couldn't go more than a i
want to say
a million gates and this is basically
because the zero knowledge proof we did
we were not careful about the memory
usage
so we need a more memory efficient zero
knowledge to actually make this work
otherwise your memory is going to
is going to blow up but
the second thing is time now the time
taken to generate these proofs
is also significant but there is a nice
feature that can be done in this thing
in this work which is that
you can actually prepare most of your
proofs ahead of time
in fact you can prove that your gobble
circuit is correct ahead of time
you don't even have to interact it is
not like normally when people talk about
an offline phase this is like a
non-interactive
phase where even before i know who i am
talking to i can build my global circuit
with the proof
and you can also think even more where i
can publish this on my web page and you
know it can be even publicly verified
so uh in our in our work we also show
here
uh how this gives a nice uh
non-interactive secure computation in
this framework where
in the offline phase where you can think
of these global circuits being published
and the receiver publishing
it's ot first message and then an online
phase there is a single message that
goes from the sender
to to the receiver in fact this is what
we implemented a question sorry
um yes are in any of those works uh do
you also study the case of multiple
parties
or so this was only for
uh two parties so i mean this is
specific to the yao protocol
right but you're asking multiple parties
sorry go ahead
you know and yes garbled circuits are
specific to the to the
to the two-party case but are there some
i don't know similar things that we're
i don't mean having a black box access
to a t
and as a commit improve sdk
functionality helps you with uh
you can you can do this i don't know how
efficient it will be but you can extend
like
you can ask right i mean the gmw
paradigm can be implemented with
oblivious transfer
can you amplify it with active security
using commit and prove yes you can
like will it be faster than previous
approaches this is yet to
but you can like i think communication
wise it will be still good
you can extend this certified oblivious
transfer for many invocations
thanks but anyways i'm going to answer
another part of your question scaling to
very large number of parties
and again i'm not going to do the
boolean setting but i'm going to take a
very specific
scenario here and i'm only going to talk
about a highlight of the result that we
did
so here is a specific task that you want
to do
using a secure multi-party computation
which is distributed generation of an
rsa modulus
where no one knows the factorization you
can envision this as a multi-party
computation where
everyone has shares of the the primes
they compute the product and check that
it's
uh it's a by prime and you know this has
gained a lot of attention at least the
past couple of years
its implication to zero knowledge its
implication to more importantly
verifiable delay functions
so what's distributed sampling of an rsa
modulus you have parties
interact to jointly sample this n each
party holds like
shares of two numbers p and q
and they're going to multiply it check
if they're prime multiply it to get
a modulus and i'm going to talk about
the scenario
where all but one can be corrupted
okay so this is our setting we want to
do distributed sampling of an rsa
modulus
and we in fact are this is another work
of
ours this is going to appear in ieee uh
in oakland next year
so we follow the gmw paradigm but you
know with a slight uh difference here so
we take
a classic passive protocol for doing the
distributed generation of rsa modulus
now as i mentioned this is how the gmw
paradigm works you commit to your inputs
and then attach a zero knowledge proof
but in the case of rsa modulus
generation there aren't quite inputs
there is only randomness you're only
sampling uh
modulus so in fact what we can do is we
can move all the zero knowledge to just
one big fat zero knowledge at the end
we don't need to do it at every step
because there is no
privacy that will be lost during the
protocol
because if it's going to be caught here
you can just restart the
the computation so
just want to tell you what our results
here are
so you know this was the best work
before this appeared by
frederickson at all in crypto 18 they
generated a 20 48-bit modulus
with passive security two parties they
used eight gigabyte ram eight core 40
giga
bit per second bandwidth per party
communication two gigabytes
and end to end time 35 seconds so what
we do is we were able to run our
protocol for a thousand parties
and in the passive setting and each
party
uh the the spec that we have is like two
gigabytes ram
and one core i should uh
and you know very nominal uh bandwidth
one megabit per second
per party communication around 150
megabytes and the end to end time was
about four minutes i should tell you
that this is
a slightly different uh setting than
this
in just one aspect in that we wanted the
party spec to be really really small
lightweight like we wanted to you know
imagine this to be
you know if you want to run it on a
browser or so forth
we involve a coordinator that
coordinates the actions
now this coordinator is doesn't come in
the trust because
you don't have to trust the coordinator
because the zero knowledge proves
and the transcript finally will even if
the coordinator cheats it will be caught
and the only thing the coordinator does
is like
public operations so when you use
like the the secure to implement secure
multiplication in such a large scenario
you use threshold
additively homomorphic encryption and
the operation that comes again and again
is like aggregation you have to add
ciphertext you have to add values
and these these are public operations
that we
involve like a trusted coordinator
not a trusted sorry an untrusted
coordinator to to do
and what i'm hiding here in this line is
that i'm not giving you the spec of the
coordinator
i mean you can throw whatever hardware
you want on the
on the uh on the coordinator because you
don't need to trust it
and we actually used the the best
machine on aws
for the coordinator but we also
implemented in the active setting
and you know for the thousand parties
you know the the zero knowledge proof is
not that big it's like about 50
megabytes so it adds
very little to the communication and our
runtime was about 22 minutes
i should tell you that you know we
didn't stop here we wanted to see how
far we could
go so we actually ran the the passive
up to ten thousand parties and the
active up to uh four thousand parties
and it kind of scaled okay like the end
to end time was like 37 minutes for
passive and 80 minutes for the active i
should tell you that these numbers
in fact can be improved if you improve
the coordinator in fact we use the best
machine on aws but
if we had more threads on the
coordinator this this this would have
improved
the point i want to make is actually
that the
the party's communication here uh
per party communication actually is
depends only logarithmically on the
number of parties
like it does it scales really really uh
really really well
and the computation of the party doesn't
change
even as you scale the number of parties
because you're only
the the computation is like sampling an
rsa modulus the circuit size
doesn't change with the number of
parties so the per party computation and
communication
really scales very well and the only
reason this blow up in time is because
we didn't get a better uh coordinator
like machine on aws
what is the round complexity so
it's 12. so each
party has to make 12 actions
so i mean for such large number of
parties how do you
i mean how would ones handle upwards
so this is dishonest majority so you
know you're not going to get guaranteed
output delivery you have to restart so
we
we introduced a kick out mechanism which
is like we waited for a minute
if not we restarted the computation
okay so this is so the way to think
about this like this particular type of
large-scale npc is that somehow
i think the parties are not uh bandits
off the internet but they're like
somewhat you know lightly prevented
so that you cannot have this dental
service attack where you know at every
retry
one party decides to cause an abort
no i mean this is definitely vulnerable
to that right like you you if
like every round some party can say okay
i'm going to go home and like
stop the uh the computation you need
some external mechanism to prevent
denial of service
i i'll also just say one point here
which is that
when i say the active protocol is 80
minutes we are waiting for all the zero
knowledge proofs to be transmitted and
verified
now you can imagine that you know you
can do this optimistically like you can
ask how many like how
long do the parties have to remain
online and that's only the passive
because you execute the passive and then
you generate the proof so
you at least in the thousand party
setting this is quite meaningful like
you just need all the parties to be
online for
four minutes and then later just you
know upload into s3 or dropbox
your proof and verify it later
how much time do i have i think
if you can wrap up the next couple of
minutes they'll be great yes i can do it
in the next couple of minutes exactly
that that's good
so the the last thing i'm going to ask
okay so you know we we got overhead 2
then we asked about less than 2 and for
the gobble circuit and for this rsa
modulus generation uh we did get less
than two you know it is like
passive protocol plus a snark
but now can we do smaller than one and
you know yeah
the question itself sounds ridiculous
but i'm going to like give
some credence to this so
this is in one of our work so we we
kind of try to leverage the leakage
resilient properties
of read solomon codes and this is what
we use at least in the first work that i
presented like the outer protocol uses
the resolument codes for
essentially for pack secret sharing so
in standard secret sharing you know the
adversary receives
t-shares in a leakage resilience setting
you have that the adversary receives t
full shares but also receives small
leakage in the remaining n minus t
shares and this is kind of the first
work that analyzed
this setting there has been a lot more
work that i've not listed over here
that as like this is a very active
research area of getting leakage
resilient secret sharing
so what we do at least we propose this
in our work in
this was in ccs last year where instead
of starting from a passive protocol
and amplifying it to active start with
the leaky protocol
and amplify it to active and
this actually makes sense when you you
know this secure multiplication
primitive gadget that i said when you
implement it using like lattice based
constructions
if you make these parameters actually
aggressive it
it is leaky and
by leveraging the leakage resilience of
read solomon codes
the the transformation that i mentioned
which is going from like using the outer
and inner protocol
you can take it from leaky to active and
we proposed a way in which
uh this can be done there's still a gap
between
what kind of leakage resilience is
provided by the scheme and what we need
like this is there's still a gap which
you know we are currently working on
but we did propose an idea where we
could go from leaky to active using the
same compiler
and this has overhead one in the sense
that
if you look at the current best passive
protocol based on these lattice
encryptions if you start with something
leaky and go to active you could get
better than that passive
so i am cheating in saying it's less
than one but this is kind of what we get
we could go
even better by starting with a weaker
primitive
and there's some other works that i'm
currently involved where we can show
that this
also imply has some connections to
getting like zero knowledge pcb
okay so this is my last slide so the
first result i mentioned was the general
framework of moving from passive to
active with constant overhead
it works for boolean and arithmetic any
number of parties works both honest
majority dishonest majority
and uses the secure multiplication
gadget in a black box way
if you relax this black box requirement
then you know you can get overhead less
than 2 by applying
like a variant of the gmw paradigm we
showed this for the boolean
uh case in the two-party setting with
double circuits and also this
distributed rsa
generation where we could scale it
really to a large number of parties
and finally like if you want to you know
push it even more you know reduce this
communication
uh start with the leaky implementation
uh instead of passive
most of this all of this works that i've
these works that i've talked about
i've only focused on the communication
overhead i should tell you that okay
this now we have a good idea of getting
a good overheads for communication
complexity
but computational complexity is still
there are many open questions
both like even the asymptotic setting is
not yet
resolved and in fact you know right now
with in the special case of zero
knowledge
we are seeing uh many constructions
where you have like linear time
uh provers but in the mpc setting like
many of these questions are still
uh are still open thank you
thank you um
i think it was right on time perfect
i think i've asked all my questions
during the talk and if stefan is there
has any questions
[Music]
all right
okay thank you so much so i think we're
done for the day here
and uh another four talks tomorrow two
in the morning two in the afternoon
um yeah yeah thank you everyone bye-bye
thanks bye